[Music]
morning in our saturday sessions a sign
of outlaw country music royalty
waylon payne i know that is not a stage
name
but it does accurately describe the
numerous hardships he's had to endure on
a long road to redemption
he catalogs his journey in a terrific
new album his first in
16 years we'll hear him perform from
that in a moment but first he sat down
this week
with anthony it's a mason
world and the road
is long named for his godfather
waylon jennings the singer waylon payne
has country in his blood you had all the
country music credentials
you could ask for yes sir ladies and
gentlemen
sammy smith my mom at the time i was
born
was probably one of the biggest stars in
[Music]
his mom sammy smith won a grammy for her
1972 smash
help me make it through the night
his dad jody payne played guitar for
willie nelson
but as an infant whalen was sent to live
with his aunt and
uncle who were strict christians at 18
payne revealed he was gay and that the
family
had a dark secret there was some abuse
going on
you were abused yeah it was a sex abuse
and that's just the way it was yeah when
it came out everybody was kind of like
no
we want to talk about it we don't
believe you and not only that we don't
want you around anymore
he didn't speak to his mother for years
mama's been crying in the kitchen
daddy's done left in the truck what was
your relationship with your dad like
i met my dad when i was 16 years old you
met him
yeah the sins of the father
are never gonna hang around me
but it was your dad also who encouraged
you to use drugs
yeah he was the first person i ever did
drugs with but first it was
beer and then it was whiskey and then it
was coking and speed
pain would become a full-blown junkie
he got by writing hits for other artists
like leanne womack
with some solitary thinking
[Music]
and with occasional movie roles
he played jerry lee lewis in the 2005
johnny cash biopic walk the line
another star in the film the singer
shelby lin
tried to help shelby believed in my
music and was like a sister and a mother
and then was the the one that sent the
tape to my mom and got my mom and i
talking again
but when his mom died in 2005
just after he'd released his debut album
payne's addiction
deepened there were a lot of people that
wanted me to get
straight and a lot of people that that
thought i would be dead you know from
some of the lyrics in your songs
it sounds like you thought you should be
dead yeah
i didn't uh i was alone
for a long long time
[Music]
not many people had expected anything of
me you know because i had burned a lot
of bridges it seems
yeah but it was uh i don't know if you
want to call it a miracle it was
just one day there was somebody there
that cared
and uh wouldn't let me fall
payne met a father figure named edward
whose own son would inspire him it was
right after i
i started working at getting sober
started thinking about it lake was born
santa anna wins is his lullaby that i
wrote for him
and the santa ana winds
they're gonna carry me back to you
april 5th 2012 was lake's first birthday
and that was the last time i ever did
methamphetamines
how did it feel when those songs started
coming well it was the first time
in a long time that they had it led to
his first album
in 16 years
the harlot how do you feel after going
through this whole journey
i'm grateful i'm grateful to be alive
and that's all i want to do is let
people know how grateful i am